james is with us in seattle hi james
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave anthony thank you guys for
taking my call sure what's up
um so my wife and i are considering
quitting our jobs and going back to
school she wants to do a career change
and i kind of want to
accelerate my master's program it's in a
it's a four-year program it's a
part-time program and i kind of want to
get it done in two years
so we were considering quitting our jobs
we make a combined 220
and the only debt that we have left is
our house which we owe about 130
um on you want to get your magic version
what
uh my master's it's my mba it's in it's
an
executive mba yeah uh my i'm a corporate
controller financial controller right
now and
i would can you make what now i make 130
and she makes 90.
and you'd like to be a cfo yeah i'd like
to be a cfo my goal is by 35.
and you think you have to have an mba to
be a cfo
um you know i've been looking a lot and
they usually require like a
cpa which i have and um an mba
i think that would help with um you know
i don't have a ton of years of
experience um you know my cfo
this is a 300 million dollar company my
cfo does not have an mba
oh gotcha yeah just as ahead wow
yeah there's a heads up yeah i'm okay if
you go get it quitting your job to go
get
it quitting it's a bit extreme yeah jobs
not just job jobs
because both y'all want to quit what is
what's her degree field what's she
wanting to go do
um she uh wanted to do um she wanted to
get she wanted to be a lawyer and then
she decided that she didn't want to do
that she's got her four-year degree
and she's a paralegal she's actually
wants to switch to health care
management
okay and she has a four-year degree in
what
uh pre-law okay and what does she do now
uh she's apparently now she's a
paralegal okay and she wants to move
into the health care field
and so she wants to get a master's in
that management she wants to get a
master's
degree either she wants to get like a
four-year degree in her
health care management how old are you
guys for her master's in health care
i'm 31 she's 29. okay
well i i have a we have
we share a view of education
that um with a few rare exceptions
the primary use of education is to
increase
income and to move into a career field
that you love okay
and so um it is not something that you
just collect like a thermo degrees on a
thermometer
and it is not something that you have to
have it is
is what is necessary for you to go win
and um in your case i would do the mba
as an executive level and keep your
position
uh would definitely not quit in her case
i would probably do the same thing i'd
probably pick
up some night classes and begin to move
towards health care as a career move
rather than just quit your jobs
you're making a great income i think you
can make a more gentle transition than
this
and i think you should